i'm back with yuna again from locket and
we're going to be discussing design
principles and the user experience and
specifically for locket what you know
you needed to get right for the user
experience I think because it's the lock
screen which is what you're so used to
your default experience so we're
basically changing that experience and
saying that this is new lock screen and
this is a real estate that you're
swiping over 150 times per day we need
to make a very user-friendly and the
goal of the lock screen is so that you
can unlock it so they can go to your
home screen right so we can't make it
too long of a process either we want to
make it simple also you don't know who
you're going to be with when you're
checking your phone that the lock screen
so it needs to be it needs to be okay
for your kids to see or for you to be
able to just like wake up to it so it
needs to be delightful as well so we're
when we were building the content on the
lock screen which is currently lock it
you know if we're just using the RSS
feeds out there and just like you know
slapping those images on the lock screen
it can it might not be delightful you
might see a lot of blood or there might
be gone involved on the lock screen so
we had to start like from a manual place
where we want to make sure each lock
screen that we're delivering to our user
is delightful and something that you
want to wake up to that you can see by
the same time we also need to deliver
these like real content which is like
hey there's an earthquake coming up so
it cannot be like a smiley face yes all
right so how do you like walk the fine
line also on the lockscreen interaction
side because you're unlocking fro
unlocking your phone and you know you
have some users that are unlocking with
the left hand versus right hand you got
to make sure that the button here on the
lock screen is something that like that
you can touch from different angles yeah
I should be able to touch it and like if
this is like two below it's hard to do
that like with one hand you have to like
hold it with both hands and also android
phones there's an effect mentation is
crazy you have like your Nexus to the
big tablet that you have the small
phones and how do you make them all look
ok on all those devices
so a lot of those considerations are
involved and also like some of the
weather how do we make the weather like
shown well in the clock people also want
to customize their lock screen so i
customized it using locket where you can
just upload your own photo and are there
any other sort of design principles we
talked a little bit about sort of
knowing your customer when they're using
the product knowing that maybe there may
be around other people what other sort
of design principles went into building
market may be in terms of like an
aesthetic view point or something like
that so when we were yeah like a few
things that we were thinking about is
like making it delightful like is this
something that you want to see on your
lock screen every single time also is it
something that you feel comfortable
sharing it with your niece or a kid that
you have you know we have a few like
guidelines as in like we have our own
locket brand guidelines where you're not
allowed to use like red on the lock
screen or or blood something like that I
can't really think of on well but it's
like we were always focusing on
delightfulness on the lock screen yeah